Go. GO!
What do you want?
Go down the slide,
or get out of the way.
You think I even want
to be here, Kyle?
My therapist told me
I need to force myself to go out
and do things
to overcome my anxiety.
Can we move him, please?
Oh, oh, I see.
People with anxiety shouldn't
be allowed at water parks,
is that it, Kyle?
Hey, everybody,
just so you know,
Kyle thinks people with anxiety
should just stay home.
Yeah. I'm trying to
come out of my shell,
but Dr. Kyle here is just
worried about his place in line.
Get off my towel.
Goddamn it. I seriously
can't get a minute of peace.
Why is it that people
who don't have
a Buddha box
are always flipping
Buddha boxes off the heads
of people with anxiety?
I got news for you, Cartman.
Everyone has anxiety.
Everyone gets nervous.
Everyone is afraid
being around people.
Everyone has feelings
they'd rather stay home alone.
And you know what they do?
They get over it, and they stop
being a piece of shit.
Everyone has anxiety?
Yes.
Oh my god, I know
what I have to do now.
You're right, Kyle.
You're right.
What? No, no, what
did I just do?
Should've just let him be
on his phone, dude.